here is Dr Fatima Cody she is the Biden
Administration Deputy of Health for 2025
first those for this current
Administration and she's talking about
the current dietary guidelines and I
just want you to listen to this woman
and you tell me if she's the best of the
best
if you diet
you lose weight
right the number one cause of obesity is
genetics that means if you are born to
parents that have obesity you have a 50
to 85 percent likelihood of having the
disease yourself even with optimal diet
exercise
sleep management Stress Management so
when people see families that have
obesity the assumption is what are they
feeding those kids
okay lady first off is there some
genetic component to obesity obviously
but do you see what they want you to do
they want you to think you have no
capacity over your own life they want
you to think that if you drink a 64
ounce Coke with all of that sugar and
you eat crap all day and they lock you
in your house and you don't exercise and
all the way you have no ability to
control any of these things do you know
what you do have ability to control it's
your own life it's the one thing that
you can probably control on this Earth
you can control how much you eat how
much you exercise but they want to
diminish those things it's why we spent
two and a half years of covid not
talking about hey get some exercise that
that obesity is the highest comorbidity
related to covid we we told people stay
at home order in all the time don't do
anything right we CL we literally close
gyms we closed beaches we told people
don't get vitamin D don't walk out there
these people are all incompetent
foreign
[Music]